Culture plays an important role in the foods to which we're exposed and
therefore the foods that we eat. If you ever seen TV shows such as the Amazing
Race or cooking competitions, you may have seen people cook foods that you
normally wouldn't eat. For example, on one episode of the Amazing Race, the
contestants had to eat frog Fallopian tubes. Now that was a delicacy for the
people of that area, but it certainty wasn't so for the Americans. On cooking
competition shows, I've seen people cook testicles, chicken feet, and even
brains. Now again, some people may find that a delicacy and actually enjoy the
flavor and taste, but many of us would not. However, if you found yourself in a
starving or near-starving situation, the chances of you eating those types of
food greatly increases. Now, we know that culture plays an important role in
the types of food we eat. But did you know that culture also plays a role in
our attitudes toward casual sex? We're going to talk about that next.